you know sometimes
in therapy when a patient
is undergoing a moment of healing of
integrating a
childhood wound of some sorts or in
clearing
the root of some trauma that is
manifesting itself in some adult
onset neurosis
a lot of times that healing experience
in the context of therapy happens in an
extremely
what you might call unself-conscious
state an extremely uninhibited state an
extremely visceral
state that is often simply labeled a
state of regression right it is said
that you regress to an earlier state of
consciousness and re-experience the
traumatic incident from the point of
view of that earlier you so we call this
regression
but i actually think there can be no
liberation or transformation
or growth of any kind without regression
in the psychotherapeutic process if you
don't go back
to the origin story
of that fear of that pathology if you
don't go back to that emotional
origin set point if you don't regress
you will not heal so in a sense the
terrifying proposition that i'm making
is that we have to be willing to
relive
uh and
re-encounter those hi please
and re-encounter those night terrors i
believe it was joseph campbell who said
the cave you fear holds the treasure you
seek
right so those those childhood traumas
then become these emotional set points
we are we don't dare revisit and so we
try to repress
and push aside and numb ourselves from
having to face those issues and so
they become they meant the this
repression manifests itself in our inner
pathological rumination and eroticism
you know and then we're trying to
medicate that and then so on and so
forth and we're a mess and it's all
because we refuse to face our shadows to
look
at the cave that we fear which in fact
is the treasure we seek and so i guess
what i'm saying is that
in the in the journey of self-knowing
right in the journey of
wanting to heal of our fractures and
come back into wholeness there is going
to have to be
a facing
of that which we fear most which is
remembering right like remembering
that thing that happened
that that traumatic
inciting incident the door we don't want
to look behind we're going to have to go
there we're going to have to lay it all
on the table we're going to have to be
like
well to to risk allowing it to destroy
us only to endure
beyond that destruction and realize that
we are more than our traumas and that
our spirit is stronger than those
traumas and so
this this this
surrendering this relapsing this
disarming
this
surrendering of all of our affordances
and and making ourselves vulnerable
again right the healing process of going
back to the place we fear
is a powerful thing but it also allows
it allows us to dispassionately see it
because that going back it's not
actually happening again right you're
reliving it but you're now safe
right in therapy there's this
this separation right that you now call
aesthetic distance you know you may be
mediated by mdma so that your nervous
system is not so triggered and primed
your mind and soul can go back but now
you're safe in the movie theater seat
watching playback in other words you can
look at it up close you can see the
thing you fear but now you're safe you
are more powerful than that thing that
thing is a mere abstraction you are a
grounded being that lives in the here
and now
and so i guess what i'm saying friends
is
no no no please please please hello
hello
hi guys
so i guess what i'm saying is that to
arrive at a place
of equanimity
to arrive at a place where we have come
to terms
with all of those issues
and come to terms with all of those
parts of ourselves that are scary and
that are ugly and that are so on and so
forth until we do that whole thing
we cannot come back into wholeness and
so this really becomes an invitation to
embrace the whole
possibility embrace the the
the surrender that is required on the
pathway to healing
have the faith to believe that you can
be brought back to life
um and that that you're safe to go back
to those places and spaces that did you
harm
and that you're strong enough to
forgive yourself and in an act of
self-compassion
make it okay
for the you
you know back then
uh
and and and
forgive yourself for what you had to do
to survive
and i think that whole process is
profoundly healing
and that final act of of sort of
redemption and self-acceptance and
self-compassion and
you know it's that moment that says one
day we'll fall down and weep and
understand it all all things but i mean
it really starts with our own
our own story um
and and
you know finding equanimity closure
grace
catharsis reconciliation
reconciliation that's the rehabilitation
is the moment where we reconciliate
where the two opposing thesis and
antithesis converge in synthesis
paradoxes reconciled healing and
resurrection is is manifested therein
it's synchronicity it's the
encapsulation of inevitability but also
surprise it's when the objective and
narrative world touch
believe that reconciliation is possible
that's how every story ends in the end
right
everything will be okay in the end
because if it is not yet okay then it is
not yet the end
so i believe healing is like life i
think the life well lived is one that
ends in reconciliation and so if we can
end in reconciliation
we've done it right
cheers